[Music]
[Music]
homie look what I become
[Music]
just a little Patrick Swayze here the
Battle of Patrick Swayze he used to live
in La Crescenta Crescenta Valley right
after he could always see his place it
was off the 210 uh freeway anyways we
are live episode 209 we were able to
make this work we got Kevin Sorbo AKA
they're Hercules in the house today
Kevin great to have you on the podcast
good to be here good to be here I'm glad
we could work it out we got a lot of
things to talk about we do so apparently
we're going to be selling a lot of books
today yeah and hopefully at the end
we'll kind of talk about some of the
stuff we got going on here with the book
but crazy times there's a lot of weird
things going on today it just gets
weirder yeah it's it's just strange it's
just strange and the mainstream media
loves her perpetuated as you know so so
so what do you what do you think so for
a guy like you who's been in
Hollywood you know people would dream to
have a career where they get a show that
takes off Hercules people I don't know
how many countries were watching 150
plus we were in 176 countries pardon the
center Pride but we can by season three
we were the most watched TV show in the
world that's pretty intense that's like
a dream for an actor to do and to be the
leading so you've gone there you've been
in it for late 80s I want to say early
90s no we shot from 93 to 2000. no no as
a professional you as an actor as an
actor I actually started in 1980 1980
yeah okay so how much 40 years so I
started when I was two I'll say but
that's not true how much has Hollywood
changed the last 40 years it's Insanity
what's going on in there look my agent
called me in about it was about 10 11
years ago my agent manager together
they're never in the same place because
they're on different sides of the Hill
there in in California and I felt like
it was an intervention but I walk in and
said we can't work with anymore because
I started getting pretty vocal on you
know on the internet and my wife says
they're going to come after you I said
why what am I I'm just saying the truth
this is the truth but apparently the
truth is a horrible thing to say on the
internet as you know so
um they they said we can't work it
anymore in Hollywood um you know Studios
say no no he's a Christian he's a
conservative we can't work with him and
I thought wow this is incredible you
guys for decades are the one screaming
for tolerance excuse me women for
freedom of speech but as you know that's
all a one-way street with Hollywood and
that's too bad because I don't Harbor
that kind of hate and anger that they
have towards people like me I just don't
I have friends that are liberal friends
that are atheists and we get along we
have a beer we play golf we give each
other a hard time but we're still
friends but it's a different world right
now in terms of
as you know the divisiveness that's gone
on and I think it's been created a lot
by some of the presidents we've had in
the past and also certainly the
mainstream media that jump on this
bandwagon to go after anybody has a
different point of view Kevin in in
Hollywood Malik if you can bring me up
about five points in Hollywood if you
look at uh some of the guys that are
able to coexist with all the other
liberals that are in there say
politically we know which side Hollywood
leans on it's not a new thing everyone
knows about it but you see some of these
guys that are still able to keep
producing and they're almost like a
Untouchable Community they I call it the
saint status where a Clint Eastwood you
can't touch him he's Untouchable yeah
Mark Wahlberg was on Fox news last week
shocking about he's moving his family to
Nevada because he wants a better
environment for his kids he doesn't want
the Hollywood thing to be there he kind
of feels like it's a better place for
him to raise his kids there are certain
guys in Hollywood that are still
producing still making some of them
obviously got blacklisted Vince Vaughn
used to do a lot of work you you got a
little bit benched for a couple years
sure then he came back maybe not at the
levels he was pre-run Paul libertarian
all that stuff that he was doing how do
some of the guys that are still
conservative people know their
conservative what makes them get away
with it in Hollywood I think like you
bring up a Clint Eastwood I think the
fact that he has been such a big star
for so many years in the A-list world I
think that he uh they know they got a
hit with him they may disagree with them
I mean was he 92 years old they still
heard he wants a direct one more movie
I've known Clint we're not buddies but
I've known them for over 25 years and I
keep saying Clint one line that's all I
want in one of your movies I just want
to say I was in the Clint Eastwood movie
but at Wahlberg I think Wahlberg's
served in that same category in the
younger generation but these guys
there's no fear with it you know I
wasn't I wasn't in the A-list world but
I was staying busy I mean after Hercules
I did a show called Andromeda for five
years and Ron berries has been up and um
you know I I stayed working but I do a
lot of independent movies Hollywood gave
me the boot but I still have the the
industry I'm still staying alive I've
shot over 45 movies since Hollywood said
goodbye you know not all of them are
great but a lot of them are pretty darn
good family movies and that's what I
want to keep doing yeah so I'm fortunate
to keep my career going but it's not
like they they can still do these big
hundreds why do you think they can do it
why do you think a uh uh for example uh
Wahlberg I want to say he's a Catholic
right when he wrote the movie uh Stu
what's the movie called father Stewart
something I watch yeah by the way it's
not a crazy movies I thought it was
going to be a better movie I'm a big
Walbrook fan sure I wouldn't say it's
his top 10 movie of all time but it
really impacted him in a way where he
kind of came out and talked about how
this movie got me thinking family all
this other stuff how long has it been
known that Wahlberg or Clint or some of
these guys are either conservative or
not part of the camp in Hollywood how
long has that been known
um well I think it varies for each of
them I think Rick Clint it's been for a
long time I mean he wasn't afraid you
know he was the mayor of Carmel up there
and that's right just for one reason
yeah and and I just think that uh
there's there's no fear factor with them
and I think that's great I think you got
guys like Bruce Willis he's been more
vocal unfortunately he's not his
Health's not very good right now James
Woods he got banned from you know
Facebook and Twitter I got banned from
Facebook for posting a truth about covid
but uh God forbid you do that Mark
Zuckerberg's a bit of a wuss and his
trolls are the same but you know you got
I'm gonna keep fighting a good fight and
uh keep speaking for the truth and we
gotta we gotta keep doing that how these
how long have these guys done it and I I
have no idea I just know that Mark
Wahlberg I think has been more vocal
lately I think Adam Sandler's on that
side too he's not as vocal but he still
has messages in his movies that show
that he is and I know I pretty knows
he's more conservative than people
probably know but um you know it's it's
I think there's a fear factor for so
many people I get actors every time that
do my movies coming to me because I
produce my own movies I've been
directing a lot lately and they come up
hey thanks for being a voice for us I
wouldn't be a voice for yourself why do
I have to be your voice well they don't
want the same thing to happen to them
that happened to me what year did this
this really start culminating like you
said you started acting in the 80s you
probably didn't notice it then you know
Clint Eastwood's been speaking at the
RNC for 20 years now whatever it is but
you must have noticed some sort of
slippery slope in Hollywood like was
there a trigger point when you start to
see the mechanics kind of Shifting and
and the woke isn't taking over when did
that was I've always seen it but I think
when Obama got elected I think 2008 was
a turning point
um not because he's half black by the
way he's also half white okay people
forget
um I just think that he brought forward
a different view of of America to people
uh you know he get his get his wife
saying I'm finally proud of being
American really you know because we're
not a perfect country but we're still a
country everybody wants to go to right
nobody's taken boats from Key West to
Cuba they're all coming across here
correct so
um to me it's like I I I started
noticing during those years especially I
think the last I think when Trump got
elected to get attacked every single day
here's a guy that both parties loves he
was on all the talk shows he was on the
magazines they had him on the ones he
decided to go for one side and say look
I'm be I'm conservative I'm gonna make
America a better place every day I don't
think no president has gone through what
he's gone through every single day of
his presidency and they still go after
him so but so you know what that does to
me though this gets me to think about
because at one point you're right Trump
was Untouchable Trump was Saint status
as Trump was you know Larger than Life
Tupac talks about I mean everybody would
you know rap about uh Trump and then he
goes out so so maybe the differentiator
is there's got to be a line you can't
cross with Hollywood for them to turn on
you you can be privately known as
conservative like a Mark Wahlberg or a
Clint Eastwood or Adam Sandler or some
of these names you're saying but as long
as you're not too vocal like a you know
James Woods as well as long as you're
not too local as yourself or some other
people will let you slide but you cannot
be too vocal you think that's kind of
what the line is there yeah I think for
me not being an a-lister but being an
actor that was still steadily working
and still have every years for the last
four decades
um I was easier to go after right away
because I'm not doing 300 million dollar
movies that are making a billion dollars
to the studio I mean they can claim they
can scream all they want that they love
socialism let's face it I mean Disney
still wants to make money they're a
capitalist business they can put on the
eyeglasses I don't know if jpeg wants to
make money yeah that's why you got fired
that's why I got rid of them yeah oh and
he was good at not making money yeah it
was very good not making money I mean
you guys hear about uh by the way two
comments one what you just said about
the covid you made a comment on Facebook
that I don't know if you guys saw this
on Twitter uh this is as of November
23rd this is an announcement effective
November 23rd 2022 Twitter is no longer
enforcing the covid-19 misleading
information policy so that announcement
was just made what does that mean
exactly which means now if you want to
push back to fauci if you want to push
back with vaccines if you want to push
back with that Twitter is no longer
Banning you like they did before that's
what they're talking about or if you
want to ask them why they're pushing
amnesty through a a very carefully
placed uh piece in the Atlantic where
they're saying oh why don't we just get
over all this and give everybody amnesty
oh really
isn't that interesting now why would you
need amnesty what do you think about you
know a guy that's been in the space what
do you think would the what's happening
with uh Disney Disney just came out with
this one movie uh uh Cartoon straight
it's a strange world yeah Strange World
Strange World I went with my son to
watch this movie apparently this movie
the customer 180 million dollars to make
they're expecting to lose 100 million
dollars it's known as their worst bomb
of all time this is back to back with
the other movie they did the what's the
light year Buzz Lightyear yeah which was
also Obama and I tweeted about this if
he can't go on Twitter I want to show
the backlash I got which was awesome it
was funny as hell so I'm watching this
movie this weekend we take the kids it's
me uh my six-year-old daughter Senna
Dylan and my 10 year old son we're
sitting there watching a movie
commercials start we like the
commercials and then the movie starts
within five ten minutes my son looks at
me says Dad I have no desire to watch
this movie let's leave right don't go to
this one go to the original one I posted
go keep going back keep going back keep
going lower or it's not going to let you
do it uh let's see if it's not going to
let you do it it's one more after that
oh my goodness keep going a little bit
more that that's one right there so zoom
in says I took the kids to watch this
movie uh Cartoon strange world within 10
minutes of the movie my 10 year old
sounds like that I have no desired
watches movie can we leave Tico says
this to me right your oldest son my
oldest son he says this and we leave
because within 10 minutes everything it
seems to be a little bit too much of
messaging and it's not even holding back
anymore it's in your face and then I got
trolled which was hilarious go back up
to some of the comments the one that you
were yeah keep going about look at this
one here this is sick look at this
dearest father it has been 10 minutes
and I'm already unentertained by this
subpar production due to the average
attention span of my age anyways people
troll Tico and they said what 10 year
old son says I have no desire to watch
this movie I said a 10 year old who's
what read 500 books right what they
don't know about they don't know who he
is literally how he talks it's so weird
father though
perpetuate this so indoctrination what
is the movie about though you know if
you haven't I haven't heard them what do
you think about it we'll talk about that
what do you think about Hollywood what
do you think about what's going on with
Disney right now specifically Disney
it's it's weird to me that they want to
cater to these lowest percentage of
people in on the planet I mean you know
uh it's I I don't I don't understand it
I don't understand this wokeness thing I
think I always think I'm one of the
first people that could you know
attacked by the walk world in the cancel
culture in Hollywood 12 years ago and
they basically said we can't work with
anymore before it became a term and uh I
I I honestly don't get it you look at a
movie like the top gun Maverick movie it
did so well because people said here's
just a movie that just you know waves
the flag certainly it does but that's
what Top Gun that hosting is all about
but it wasn't pushing this agenda or
pushing that agenda we didn't even know
who the enemy was we know they didn't
want to date they didn't want to do that
either but you know but at the same time
it was just a movie that was just fun to
watch and it was just uh you know it it
did so well because it catered to the
audience that still wants to go see
theaters yeah I don't you know people
get mad there was a movie was this the
one that had the gay relationship in or
something so they get mad because people
don't want to see that and you're going
well let people see what they want to
see I thought there's supposed to be a
free country and we're supposed to go
what do we want you know oh yeah I'm not
telling Disney not to do what they're
doing with the movies but that why am I
doing movies that are totally opposite
that have Love and Hope and laughed and
Redemption those are the kind of movies
I want to do and those are the movies
that people keep telling me to make but
I don't have a 100 million dollar budget
like they do to advertise it because
they did that's what they did a movie
like that needs to get to about 500 600
million dollars to break even and that's
why they keep doing movies like Avatar
and Avengers and things that they need
to get to that level but they're going
to make two billion dollars in theaters
they're gonna make Pirates of the
Caribbean 14. they're going to keep
making these movies
and they'll keep doing it so you you
think that's impurity Johnny Depp to 300
million dollars to do pirates of the
kids probably and you think he's gonna
accept it probably
you might have heard he's had some legal
troubles yeah but when you said you said
the term they keep playing to the lowest
percentage of people what do you mean by
that exactly well it just seems like
they wanted okay what what percentage of
the population is transgender 0.5
yeah exactly fine people want to to do
that we're like fine I'm not racist
towards that or hate people that go
through that in fact I feel sorry for
some because what I've read about it
they go through a lot of things
psychologically as well a lot of trauma
yeah a lot of trauma in this world and
then the gay population I love when they
call me homophobe I've been in the
business 40 years I work with gay people
in every set I've been on you won't find
one that said he was so mean to me they
won't but it's easy just being a
conservative is enough for them to say
oh he hates gay people no we don't but
it's easy to have that Mark and they
have their labels but that's all they
have is their labels they don't have
things to back it up they have these
little labels that the media tells them
to say you're racist you're homophobia
you're anti-semit they say all this
stuff well they're actually the ones
that are anti-semite but anyway it's a
weird world out there right now where
they come after you for anything I mean
the people that attack me on Twitter I
can say great day in the golf course I
hope you die you know these these people
have nothing better to do with their
lives and to me I feel more sad for them
I don't feel anger towards them I feel
like my God what kind of Life did they
lead when they got to wake up every
morning look in the mirror and hey what
they see what a horrible way to go
through life every day you're saying
like the law of large numbers that 0.5
five percent five percent two percent
whatever the number is they're catering
to that audience then the 90 plus
percent you know what it's weird yeah
it's called the loudest what business
are you in you're in what business the
life insurance business but you're not
you're not just in the Life Insurance
business so the life settlement business
correct okay so life settlement imagine
if you started targeting 20 year olds
yes and your commercials for Life
settlement which is what for clients
that are above 78 let's just say right
seven five and up right correct correct
imagine if these life settlement
companies started targeting 18 year old
kids saying you think about your life
insurance policy 18 year old kids can
say what the hell I guarantee you ninety
percent of people listening to this
right now don't even know what life
settlement is correct like I'm sorry let
me Google here's what life settlement is
you're 75 years old you have a five
million auto insurance policy you got a
two million dollar insurance policy
everybody you love is no longer alive
and your kids who you had insurance for
no longer need insurance because they're
married their career is fine they're
doing good but your premium used to be
200 a month now it's 500 a month now
it's two thousand dollars a month you
can't afford it so you got five million
dollars a guy like this comes up to you
and says listen I'll pay you 18 for your
two million dollar policy you're paying
however much money I'll pay you 18 for
it what's 18 360
000 here give us a two million dollar
insurance policy we'll pay the premium
you're 78 years old based on your life
expectance you're gonna die at 85 we'll
take the risk okay cool 360 I'm alive I
get the two million dollar policy I'll
make the exchange right if an insurance
company targeted 18 year olds that's
stupid practice okay and that's what
Disney's doing so on the capitalism side
it's dumb practice because capitalism
eventually exposes dumb ideas and
Disney's getting exposed for dumb ideas
Bob shape where they had to beg a bob
Iger to come back which Bob Iger is
sitting there saying I may have some
political aspirations that he has to put
on pause because the guy went from being
a Democrat to apparently is a more in
the independent middle right now and he
was kind of having the conversation when
he was buying 21st Century Fox when
Murdoch asked him and said hey any
aspirations around it for office not
really even who was thinking about
running for president well Bob Iger save
it then there's the other part so one is
capitalism he's going to expose you know
what the other part is here's the other
part
sitting there with the movie it's
literally the scene when it happens so
so far I'm trying to figure out what's
going on with this cartoon because I
actually like watching cartoons I like
cartoons I'm the 44 year old guy that
likes watching a good cartoon and then
all of a sudden you see this uh 10 year
old kid blushing when another 10 year
old kid what highlight shows up it's
like oh my God and I'm like wait what
and they kind of like I'll keep I said
okay I get you what you're trying to do
you want to say that we have a high Dei
score because everything you have meets
the guidelines of that Community okay
one uh don't forget who your customers
are
kids are not buying 20 tickets parents
are you're an idiot if you think parents
are going to sit there most parents are
going to sit there and say well you know
what it's okay now a lot of parents are
going to say no it's not okay and then
they're going to go to a different place
so then the the rumor mill goes into the
story which I want to read any time I
want to get your commentary on this
crazy story no it's not true there's no
way this would ever happen we never
talked about this we've never had any
kind of an interest in this this isn't
true it's just a bunch of people writing
about it can we stop talking about this
topic here I want to see where the story
is by the way there it is okay page four
I remember let me read this to you so um
crazy rumor says Bob Iger might want to
sell Disney to Apple in a move worthy of
HBO's TV show hit succession Disney
announced late on Sunday that Bob Iger
is replacing chapek as CEO shapeg was
the CEO of Disney for nearly three years
he was iger's pick for the job when he
retired from his tenure as CEO niagara's
new mission is to find another
replacement but Disney's insiders now
claim that iger's ultimate goal might be
to sell the company with apple being the
most likely buyer we have been we have
seen speculation in the past
that either Disney or apple would be
interested in such a deal previously
Iger noted that Steve Jobs was a close
friend a Disney Apple merger might have
been on the table if it weren't for jobs
ultimately death in 2011 with Igor's
return to Disney insiders are already
speculating that his mission might be to
sell the company and the Apple's name is
popping up again one such Insider talked
to ramp saying that igrow will sell the
company this is the Pinnacle deal for
the ultimate deal maker the unnamed
Insider claim this is not verified
nobody knows can it happen Tom what are
your thoughts on the story well I think
what's going on is it it has to happen
what you have to do is don't think if
Disney is a Content company right now
think of in this Entertainment Company
so and they have all these legs of
entertainment they got the theme parks
they make their own movies but they've
also know that the control has shifted
because all of the the expensive
infrastructure guys are going bankrupt
right it'd be whether it be DirecTV
whether it be dish or delivering hard
cable all of that is a losing business
over the top is everything and we all
call it streaming if you take a look at
it Hulu's got about 10 11 of total
streaming market now and Disney plus has
got about 15 so that's 25 percent of it
remember that's of spend because Hulu
gives you live sports local channels all
that Disney plus gives you the Marvel
Library actually like the Hulu product I
just got turned on to it a recently
product I love the Hulu product I'm a
long time subscriber and then Disney
plus has got massive libraries that's
really a Netflix competitor if you think
about that they got the Marvel they got
lucasfilms they have all their own stuff
um now you step back and look at it and
say wait a minute what have Apple TV
what library do they have well they
don't really how are they able to
compete with YouTube and with Hulu to be
the cable provider so you get your local
channels and all the other stuff with it
right the answer is they really can't
they're kind of stuck at seven percent
if Apple buys Disney you instantly have
one third share of the streaming dollars
and a quarter of the over the top cable
subscribers that's huge and so now you
have consolidation and you have to step
back and look at and I'll do a tangent
here but I think people understand it
remember a day about 10 years ago we had
about seven mobile phone companies
United States now we have basically
three T-Mobile which includes Sprint
Verizon ATT that is 95 so the
consolidation happens so Iger
yesterday was asked about Disney uh
selling to Apple and you heard he said
he said I don't think Disney is going to
be making any massive Acquisitions for a
while I'm very interested in reducing
the 1.5 billion loss we had on streaming
at Hulu wait a minute wait a minute that
wasn't the question was answered I
wasn't asking if you would make a large
acquisition I was asking if Apple would
acquire you and he very skillfully
answered it a very specific way and I
took I took note of that and I believe
what's going to happen here the
over-the-top consolidation has to
continue it's a big if Apple does that
they already have a monopoly only in
Twitter over the weekend the last couple
days Yep this would be massive if Apple
pulled this off and by the way if
there's anybody that has the cash to
pull it off that can do the financing
it's one company that's Apple Kevin have
you ever worked with Disney
um I have I have they're actually the
sitcom for them and when Andromeda
finished in 2005 I did a sitcom that was
owned by them because they owned ABC as
well and uh it was called uh Bobby
Cannon it's an idea that uh I came up
with my with my old manager we wrote out
the um you know 10-page outline for the
series The Bible for the series we got
Barry Kempton coming to write a berry
Camp rope he created the coach series
with Craig T Nelson he created The Bob
Newhart series Norm MacDonald's a really
good writer and uh we actually tested
number one of their of their 20 they had
about 28 Pilots that year they know what
year was this uh 2005. okay go on you
can see Bobby Ken it's online I I play
an aging quarterback for the Chicago
Bears at the end of his career it's kind
of like coach meets cheers in a way
still a Playboy still playing around
Kate Walsh was in it playing my
biographer she went on to private
practice for many years Rocky Carroll
who's been in NCIS the last decade great
cast and um we tested number one for ABC
and they didn't pick us up
welcome welcome to the politics of of
Hollywood who knows what they are people
don't realize that each of these Network
guys
that run it CBS NBC Fox whatever they
the presence they get the final say so
there's a lot of good shows out there
that people will never ever ever know
about there it is right there people
will never know about the show and
they'll never um and it's a great show
we tested number one they bring me to
New York for upfront say picked it up
the next day to decide not to pick it up
I went from like riding High I think
that um USA Today did a big article on
me saying uh Kevin Sorbo from hurt to
Kirk because I played you know Captain
Dylan Hunt but you know it's a sequel to
to centers is he now the king of comedy
the big article on me wow it was very
exciting very cool because I've done a
number of guest spots I was on murdered
sure I was on three Two and a Half Men
I've done uh diamond Greg all these
different shows uh and I figured this is
gonna be awesome I love the live
audiences it was a blast we had a great
time with the show it's absolutely
hilarious and they don't pick it up how
are the decisions like that made by the
way I have who knows really I think
there's politics involved yeah but they
have I think they have a thing in there
um that they call it I can't remember it
was it was the head of Laura art one
time
and he uh they came up with the rule
ruling because this is what happened
there was a series Jag you may have a
joke
well the first season was NBC or
whatever going to CBS um the last
moonves law that's what they call it so
what happened was the show um they
didn't like the ratings on the show so
CBS says well we'll buy it they buy it
it becomes a massive top 10 hit for 10
12 years so they don't want to be
embarrassed anymore by doing a show that
they pull off the air so now they sit on
the shelf for five years they you have
to sign a contract we own it for five
years no matter what happens to it and
the pilot so they don't do it they let
it die of attrition on the Shelf instead
of actually putting it back out there
for people and the egos of all these
guys coming in they don't want to take
an old show from somebody else anyway
and redo it they want their own show
with their own people and that's what
happens when any you know Network or
Studio gets taken over by somebody new a
lot of people lose their jobs and they
bring in their own people so this is the
battle with that show it's a great great
show and it's unfortunate that it didn't
go but that's part of the the deal you
gotta fight with these guys because it
happens all the time and that it killed
me when that show didn't go Kevin did
you ever in in your career in Hollywood
did anybody ever sit you down and say
Hey Kevin relax you're talking too much
you got a good Courier be quiet you know
keep your politics to yourself it's
going to hurt your career you shouldn't
be doing it's any big name people ever
give you counsel like that or no Tom
Selleck Tom Selleck we're walking it was
uh 2007 or eight we're at the Emmy
Awards and uh we're walking into the
Governor's Ball afterwards and awards
show is over and he's always been a cool
guy I don't I don't know him well but
every time I met him he's always just
been a classic Magnum PI bro with his
armor put his arm around me and he said
Kevin you got to keep quiet you know and
I at that time I was like this like 2008
I said how loud am I being I mean and it
was just like now you got to be careful
because the trust me people talk and
sure enough it happened but he was
probably the biggest one that came up to
me and said something you know other
than my wife saying stop what you're
doing and and at any point where you're
like gotcha Tom let me let me let me
actually heed your eyes I didn't or you
just said nah I'm gonna do me I didn't
know it was at that time I was like oh
what am I saying this but I'm speaking
the truth but you can't speak the truth
you know what were you saying in oh wait
that was the truth like obviously these
days it's a little more
contentious covered this lockdowns no
yeah what was the drama in in 08
honestly I can't remember but I know
that I was out there being a
conservative I was out there being a
Christian and I I wasn't like walking on
the set you know trying to convert
people in like that but when people
would say something on the set I would
always confront them one to one I go
what do you mean about that what do you
I don't understand what your your terms
of abortion why are we even talking
about this why did you bring that up and
it was just it was just weird to me that
all of a sudden that started getting out
there more and more and more I guess
from me being just more vocal about it
and Tom noticed it and said something to
me and and Tom is Tom's Courier still uh
um going is he still doing shows he's on
Blue Bloods it's been on for like 10
years yes and Tom yeah Tom whose show
was Tom on when him and her went at it
uh was it rozio rosie no was a Whoopi
Goldberg no not Whoopi Goldberg it was
another one who she had a show and then
she got kicked off it was it was what
was it
um it is a Rosie that's Rosie O'Donnell
rosie no Rosie and Rosie O'Donnell no
Rosie the other one yes where her
daughter just turned one that the one
that Trump always has yeah yeah yeah
he's uh oh man Rosie Perez not Rosie
Perez oh my God Ricky Lake oh man no I
did a Regular Show I did I was on
Rosie's show
girl I was on Rosie's show I was
remembering on that show anyways there
was a uh I'll think of it I'll think of
it here I'll bring it up by the way uh
uh it's interesting again hearing these
things because Tom select who is also
been vocal maybe not at the levels like
yourself in James Woods because you guys
are like on steroids you guys you guys
haven't slowed down at all both of you
guys are very vocal so when I said the
story about uh Disney yes guy Kevin
sends me this picture he says we just
got off a Disney cruise and he says on
the cruise this is one of the guys that
was telling the story to the kids I said
okay what's wrong with the picture he's
telling a nice story he says look at
what he's wearing shoes I'm like What's
He wearing Mark Jacob can you zoom in
zoom in he's wearing high heels talking
to to kids yeah okay so look
this is going to confuse parents where
parents are going to say I'm sorry
Disney I'm just not taking my kids to
the cruise period there's going to be a
lot of parents that don't want to answer
unnecessary questions yet to an
eight-year-old kid it's too early to
have those types of conversations when
you get things like this this is not
controversial this is the average parent
doesn't want to talk about you know a
lot of different topics that they don't
want to talk to them about this being
one of them so if Disney thinks this is
okay to say what's wrong with that let
them do that kind of things you again
Disney don't understand who your
customers and to you have lost control
of your company your brand what it stood
for you have fully lost control and it's
it's to the point where they are walking
on eggshells wondering what they need to
do to turn the company around one of the
best things we witnessed during covet
one of the best things we witnessed
during covid was a case study of Disney
one was Disneyland the other one was
Disney World right California Florida
that was great one was Disneyland hey
you know we're gonna do this and we're
gonna do that and we're gonna shut and
Disney World's like nah California Calif
because remember
Bob biker was sitting on the board with
Gavin Newsom to help going through this
process and then California shuts down
the park and then Bob Iger resigns from
Gavin newsom's Camp says listen man I
don't want to help you out anymore
because what you're doing I'm against
Disney loses 78 000 jobs DeSantis keeps
Disney World open the restaurants around
all stay in business they're not
affected by it because people are going
to Disney World and the businesses
around that were making money when
people were staying at Disney World
staying intact then they interviewed the
businesses around Disneyland that no
longer got the traffic they got
destroyed Disney has screwed it up so
bad the last 24 36 months if they don't
get their act together hell of course
someone's gonna buy him out uh at a
Pennies on a dollar and some Scott
Rodriguez was a valetaner he's a PPD
podcaster a member uh he just gave a
Super Chat 50 bucks and he said I was
just at Disney World November 11 till
the 20th with the family this was the
sixth time going on in the last 10 years
pbd we are a Disney family I can tell
you the magic is gone and it's so sad
Apple buying Disney will ruin Disney
apple is so woke anyway so Apple's even
woker than Disney oh yeah he's saying
Apple can I ask you a question because
you've got four kids all basically 10
and under yep uh Kevin you've got I got
three okay how old are they 17 18 and
21. okay so you've got teenagers in
college age Tom you've got teenagers yep
you know I've got a nephew who's 10
right and all my buddies all have kids
they're all between five and 12 years
old I don't have kids
um but is it is that the common
denominator it's just like listen I
don't think anybody cares what you do in
your private life you want to be gay you
want to be trans like go for it yeah I
mean I'm from Florida my sister went to
UCF she worked at Disney all her friends
were gay they're all the musical theater
kids that go to I work a lot I don't
work a lot of gay ass literally nobody
has a problem with them but I mean I'm
speaking as as not a parent I'm more
asking you guys is that where you draw
the line obviously it's like look do
what you guys want to do we really don't
care but when you start trying to
indoctrinate six-year-olds 10 year olds
12 year olds that's where we have our
problems I say let people grow up and
find out where they want to be in their
life when they grow up why there's
forcing on them when they're five six
years old what the Santas did was saying
this is ridiculous to do these to kids
that don't say gay let them figure out
if they're great and under I went
through high school and there when I
went to class reunions five and ten
years later and then like five or six of
the guys that I had no idea Were Gay
we're gay now and I said did you have to
hide this during high school did you
know back then a couple of them said
yeah but I didn't know that yeah I
couldn't have cared less if they were or
not but it was interesting that they had
to hide it and I think that's their
biggest battles we need to not be afraid
to come out we'll find to come out in
today's world I don't think anybody's
afraid anymore especially in America you
know just go go for it which is fine but
I think people are tired of being forced
under throats constantly it's constant
going on it's like every commercial
every it's like fine congratulations you
know I mean it's it's just it's gotten
to a point now that people just I just
fed up with it and I think people are
getting more vocal about it now
listen let me let me tell you what what
is going on right now which is I think
it's going to take two years to come out
of this and it's not going to be easy I
think it's going to be very ugly you
know how I said I think Twitter is going
to be a trillion dollar company yeah I I
still firmly believe Twitter is going to
be a trillion dollar company I'm betting
that it's going to be a trillion dollar
company Elon Musk thinks within a year
he can have a billion active users on
Twitter and I got to tell you I used to
Twitter was at the bottom of my apps
being used I'd never use Twitter I was
very inactive on Twitter I would do
something here and there but it wasn't
something I was like let me get active
on Twitter Twitter's a more funner
product the last four weeks since he's
bought it way before I'm more active on
Twitter than I've ever been because of
what's happened with them now watch this
now watch who's lost their minds and
what they're doing and how hypocrisy
gets exposed can you pull up uh Alyssa
Milano's tweets I know what the Hodge
twin said to him to her I don't know if
it's a him or her I think Alyssa
Milano's uh her
um definitely her I don't want to offend
her uh Alyssa Milano says I give my
Tesla back I give back my Tesla I bought
a VW EV I love it I'm not sure how
advertisers can buy space on Twitter
publicly traded companies products being
pushed in alignment with hate and white
supremacy doesn't seem to be a winning
business model Hodge twins Volkswagen
was literally founded by Nazis and
Hitler and that gets 173 didn't do her
homework and then Elon Musk laughs and
you see what happens there this is the
best part when people open their mouth
all of a sudden
um you're able to filter out through
people's bullshits and this is why
Twitter is winning today and Alyssa
Milano is trying to find the smallest
hole in the world to go hiding so people
can't find her there isn't anything more
embarrassing than this if we had a dummy
of the week segment this is we this
could be the dummy of the Year segment
although there's a lot of other people
that are competing with her what do you
think about this posted a lot of dummy
of the Year events there's a World Cup
we're going on right now you know with
the whole mask wearing thing too I mean
I've talked to plenty of doctors be on
closed walls you know closed doors and
they said I know the masks are useless
we all knew that was I mean it was just
crazy you know walk in the restaurant
where it's sit down you can take your
mask off really so I guess in the booth
I'm safe I'm getting coffee I mean the
whole hypocrisy and she showed one that
she I guess she crocheted her own yes
because I'm it's just uh but you know
it's it's it's it's what that's it's out
there now and people do this kind of
stuff I'm on Twitter please follow me on
Twitter I do very funny Twitter
sarcastic twitters and uh so at K sorbs
because my buddies call me sorbs that
case orbs check it out I posted stuff
like you know you want to get rid of
kova tell the clintons covet's got
something on them that was one of them I
put out there I said fetterman fetterman
and um Biden for 2024. it's a no-brainer
I mean that's the kind of stuff I put
out there so to me I just have fun with
it and you got through trolls out there
attacking every time but I don't care I
I feel sorry for you trolls I really do
I hope you get your lives together and
actually find purpose in your life but
but again this is a great thing about
capitalism okay somebody like a musk
comes and buys Twitter people lose their
minds but here's where I believe the
connection is with Disney with apple
with Twitter and this is deeply
concerning let me kind of give you an
idea what my worry is here so Elon so
first of all MPR let me read the article
with the 50 advertisers if you want to
pull that up the article about 50
advertisers you put on a different
section let me see what that is Page 10.
okay if we go to page 10 here's a story
about what's happened with Twitter okay
if you want to pull it off so the
audience can see this 50 of Twitter's
top 100
advertisers have pulled out from the
platform since Elon Musk took over
Reports say this is an Insider story
uh in the 25 days since ilamas took over
Twitter half of his top 100 advertisers
stopped advertising on the platform
according to research center Media
Matters again Media Matters since 2020
those 50 companies have accounted for
nearly 2 billion dollars in advertising
Revenue this year alone they spent 750
million dollars those 50 companies
that's a big number by the way the some
of those companies like Chevrolet Ford
Chipotle have publicly announced that
they were stopping advertising on
Twitter media matter says the others
quiet quitters because it's analysis of
pathmatics data shows that they have
stopped advertising for a significant
period of time Coca-Cola Kellogg's meta
and amongst
are amongst those who have pulled their
advertising budgets away from Twitter
according to Media Matters the list of
all 50 is available in Media Matters
report the media center cites direct
Outreach controversies and warnings from
media buyers as causes behind those
companies decisions so now 750 million
dollars going to 2 million dollars
Revenue this year on 750 million dollars
let's do the math 750 million dollars
divided by 12 is what about 60
two million dollars 62 million dollars
divided by eight dollars uh is what 62
divided by eight so 62 divided by eight
is nine million seven million divided by
eight you need
7.75 million people per month to pay
eight dollars a month to match that 750.
that's not a big number here's what's
scary listen all the advertisers if this
guy pulls off
20 million people paying eight bucks a
month if 20 million pay eight bucks a
month he can give the middle finger to
the advertisers it's game over from
there because he no longer needs their
money now why is this so important
here's why this is so important
he tweets something to Apple can you
pull the Tweet up about Apple I want to
get your thoughts on this one here uh
not this one there's a 30 App Store no
no he calls that Tim Cook if you just go
to uh go to his account it should come
up uh uh if you go to his account go up
a little bit and he says uh
um I hope you have it uh there's a go a
little bit more a little bit more I hope
it allows you to do it oh man there's a
part about him calling out
there it is right there right there
right there go up go up one more so
click on that okay click on that right
there that says what's going on here Tim
Cook okay what's going on here Tim Cook
no response go a little lower go a
little lower I think he responds okay
there it is Apple has mostly stopped
advertising on Twitter do they hate free
speech in America Tim Cook doesn't
respond
no one's saying anything so then the
threat comes out that they're thinking
about potentially dropping the Apple app
I'm sorry the Twitter app off of Apple
so wait a minute you're going to
potentially drop Apple Twitter app off
Apple yes if that happens Tom what
happens think about it if if Apple drops
it off guess who has to drop them off
afterwards Droid because they have to
match the two what happens if they drop
Twitter off the app well most people
don't know is there are 51
Android based
handset manufacturers in the world do
you think one of them would like to make
20 million handsets a year for Elon Musk
I think so also if you look inside cars
your telematics inside your car that's
an Android device Android is ubiquitous
and it would be not difficult for must
to get a phone look look at the
technology puts into Tesla look at he's
got in that dashboard this this would
not be a difficult thing to get an
Android manufacturer make an Android
based phone and put it on there himself
and I think people know it I think Apple
knows it and I think Google knows it and
so the question is I believe from a
capital standpoint one of those and
probably Big G or alphabet is waiting
for this to blow over because there's a
lot of money to be made a lot of money
to be made on Twitter I think he he
would have another phone not by Tuesday
but he would have another phone and that
is not what Apple would want in America
but um the two get another phone how
long does it take to get another phone
you have 51 out there that are making
phones right now
they're making phones for all these
houses I think where the technology has
at his disposal I don't think it would
take that long it would not take a it
would not take a year to get it out
probably wouldn't take it this is what's
been going viral right now if you can
show this on the screen this is what
everybody's been talking about I think a
Tesla phone would do well I don't know
about a Twitter phone I think a Tesla
phone designed by the engineers I think
people would buy a Tesla phone and it
would be kind of sexy hey what do you
have about Tesla well Tesla already has
the app you can start your phone you can
program your car you can do everything
on that so there's a lot going on I this
is the same thing that happened like
four years ago or whatever three four
years ago in Georgia if you remember
there was an abortion thing they were
coming up the heartbeat built yeah
Hollywood all up in arms because they
love murdering children so they love
childhood sacrifice but we can talk
about that later
um so oh we're gonna pull out we're not
gonna film in Georgia anymore so what
happened nothing nothing happened
because Georgia has the number one
industry right now for filming movies
and TV they are completely sold out I
Know Dan Kathy Chick-fil-A CEO his
studios are totally booked for the next
two years 100 booked all these big 300
million dollar movies go out there they
can scream communism socialism all they
want they like you said they're still a
capitalist business they want to make
money they're going to go 30 35 back
from from filming in Georgia I got a 300
million dollar action movie I'm gonna
get 100 million dollars back of course
they're going to stay in Georgia it's
insane these these are just idle threats
trust me all the stuff will pass over
they're not going to do anything because
they they know down the long run they're
gonna they're gonna lose so let me get
this straight so let me get this
straight so I'm gonna play The Devil's
Advocate and I'm going to play only the
paranoid survive you're saying there's
no way Apple drops the Twitter app
no way Apple drops a Twitter app off
their iOS
you don't think they will
both of you guys I don't think they will
I think it's I think it's a risky bet
baby I think it's a very Risky Business
cooler heads will prevail they're going
to talk about this this is the line look
what you just pointed out just now
they're going to look at everything down
the road and they say well you know that
doesn't really add up personally because
someone else's gonna jump in and take
this business away from us so I think if
Tim Cook's put in a corner does he like
pull it and put him on probation and
then say we have an agreement for this
and then put it back you know I could
see a head fake Pat I don't see Tim
pulling it down so so I'm going to give
you why he would and then I'm going to
give you why he won't and then let's
have this nice debate yeah so I have a
question for you on Elon I can ask you
before let me just go through this one
you can ask the question about Elon so
here's why I believe he could and this
is the one thing nobody is paying
attention to
Apple faces shortfall of 6 million
iPhones okay the new ones that came out
the pros because protests against
covid-19 restrictions are impacting
production Reports say so if you read
this story on page six and it talks
about uh The Six Million shortfall the
tech giant as a factory in Zhengzhou
City located in the central Chinese
province of henan where a recent
covid-19 breakout occurred Foxconn the
company that makes iPhones for Apple
runs the factory person familiar with
the operations inside zhangju Factory
who requested to remain anonymous tool
told Bloomberg the estimate the
estimated short film production could
change they added the that it depends on
how fast fastcon can uh coax uh co-works
workers back into the plant etc etc Okay
so
if if there's one word we did a case
study on my Tick Tock account very
interesting and we made this video
yesterday
I'm going to show you numbers and I want
you to tell me if this makes any sense
you ready I'm going to show you a case
study okay this video is going out in a
week or two I didn't want to start a
tick tock because I know what was going
on with Tick Tock and anything tied with
China I was not comfortable with and
people said no listen the bike dance got
to be careful I said let me do a case
study on Tick Tock and see if this thing
works so we start uploading videos all
of a sudden a couple videos get five
million views three million views two
million I'm like okay cool motivation
does fine all this stuff does fine
couple things are doing fine then
data this is pure data for you to do
case study we looked at what's happened
with my Tick Tock account the last two
months versus prior to the two months so
we took two timelines one was from June
7th of this year to August 5th so to try
to track these numbers here I know we
don't have it there to see it it's June
7th to August 5th Tom if you're tracking
this two months yes August 5th and then
we did August 5th to November 23rd okay
if you're tracking August 5th to
November 23rd which means August 5th to
November 23rd a couple days ago and then
prior to that we went June 7 to August
5th June 7 to August 5th I uploaded 264
clips
on tick tock of the 264 Clips uploaded
on Tick Tock we broke it down in four
categories how many of them got zero to
twenty thousand views how many they got
20 to 100 000 views how many got a
hundred thousand two million and how
many got over a million here's the
numbers zero to twenty thousand 99
videos uploaded on tick tock
twenty to a hundred thousand 111 videos
102 million 45 and 9 got over a million
and my Tick Tock account was small fifty
thousand followers eighty thousand
followers during this period then my
Tick Tock account hits 260 000 followers
and here's what's happened in the last
two months this is 722 videos last two
months versus 264. let's look at the
data out of seven hundred and twenty two
thousand twenty two videos how many Tom
you think got over 20 000 views
well if it was going to be the same you
should have had about 400 of them out of
720 Clips only two got over 20 000 views
720 got zero to twenty thousand views
only one over a hundred thousand did you
understand the number I just gave you
guys 722 only two went over twenty
thousand views we're looking at this
case study Raul from India is giving me
the message saying what the heck is
going on here then we found the bogey on
when everything changed
on August 5th I uploaded a video
criticizing China on Tick Tock oh that's
right you did the rap thing ZZ not the
guy for me I uploaded the clip on China
on Tick Tock yep like this everything
just went through boom all the way down
China you can look at it August 5th is
what the date is but here's the point
the point is by the way the same Clips
they're watching the same Clips we
measured on Instagram got 9.5 million
views got 9 500 views on Tick Tock yeah
6.8 million views 3.8 million views 2.9
million views 2 000 views five thousand
views three thousand views on Tick Tock
comparison Instagram to tick tock so as
much as Instagram is woke Tick Tock is
at a whole different level the reason
why I think
Twitter could potentially do this I mean
Apple could take Twitter down is the
following reason what is one of the
scariest things that happened after 9
11. what did George Bush and is in the
Department of Homeland surgery
yeah outside of TSA they came out with
one other thing what did they come up
with outside of TSA they came out with
something called the Patriots okay what
did Patriot actor really say to us what
can they do that they could look at all
your stuff they can do what they can
look at what do they need my permission
to investigate into they can do anything
right they don't have your they don't
need your permission specifically it was
two things to go into your cell phone
records and also to subpoena email
suppliers so now anything that you've
whoever you've dialed and talked to
whoever you've emailed they can get the
list let me tell you if Patriot Act was
for America what Tick Tock in China is
doing is for the world and if Tick Tock
in China has the kind of data where they
can track what's on your phone you're
given information Rogan read this on his
podcast and people were blowing away
that thing got a few billion views
everybody's sitting there oh that's
right you read the Privacy read the
Privacy report saying they can look at
your finger what movements you make on
your phone Tick Tock has the right to
measure that on your phone on other apps
you're logging on to it's tick tock is
Patriot Act on steroids and if Apple
drops
Twitter off their app it has to do with
Tick Tock it has to do with China that's
how all of these things get tied up on
the flip side of it I'm a Tim Cook fan
okay uh I don't know if a lot of people
know or not Tim Cook is a uh he wouldn't
say this publicly but if you've read
about him and if you've read books on
them I've read a lot of different
material and books on this guy he's a
gay Republican okay he's not a Democrat
he is a republican he grew up in a very
uh conservative family he ended up
becoming gay himself but he is somebody
that fiscally Obama didn't like some of
the stuff that he did when they went to
him tell us what happened with the phone
in San Bernardino says I'm not going to
be doing it they didn't like the fact
that the FBI have the information so so
now we're gonna find out if Tim Cook's
backbone if he's gonna stand up to China
bullying him because he's gradually
moving production away from China to
India and other places we're going to
learn a lot about Tim Cook over the next
three to six months I don't think it's
going to be 12 to 24 months I think it's
going to be three to six months if they
move
Twitter off the app China and Tick Tock
are more powerful than people think if
he doesn't Tim Cook is a g and we're
going to find that out next three to six
months that's my opinion I may be wrong
thoughts I'm you know I'm with you at a
certain level and I step back and I just
look at how quickly because you have to
remember what this does this if Tesla
made a phone if you know must makes a
phone under any other name or calls it
the Twitter phone it doesn't matter it
becomes the destination
for all things canceled and that is 25
of the hard
citizenry of the United States and up to
40 percent of those that identify firm
conservative and so be careful what you
wish for be careful what you wish for
they could he could be creating do you
understand what I'm saying does this
this ability to suck the air out of the
room oh we've been canceled and it's
been canceled well then all those social
media things that we're trying to be
built remember they got they got
themselves canceled off of uh what was
it parlor and they got Amazon to turn
off their servers there's a lot of
things
I think that this opens the floodgates
for like a third force and I don't think
anybody wants that to happen not on not
on the left they just want it to be shut
up they don't want to it to be the
enabler of uh a third a third
alternative
everybody forgets that Elon Musk wants
to turn Twitter into WeChat and WeChat
is the Chinese app where you can order a
car pay money social media order your
food do your drug like it's everything
yeah these are known as super apps
exactly that's what he wants to do as
well yes that's what he wants to turn
Twitter into right he he will eventually
Supply the everything app on his own
Tesla phone yesterday where he presented
his six business plan slides anybody see
that yeah he tweeted did you see that of
course I did of course guess what pull
it up pull it up that didn't take long
by the way check this out pull it up
this is three weeks and he had a more
aggressive strategy than anybody else on
the market zoom out a little bit so if
you look at this data we're recruiting
new signer sign ups or at an all-time
high user active minutes also at an
all-time high there's one one the data
that you really have to see keep going
uh uh daily active users eight speech
Impressions uh are lower by the way you
see those two spikes you see those two
spikes can you in a little bit on those
two spikes you see those two spikes
since he bought the company how it went
up to hate speech Impressions 10 million
and everybody started saying I'm
noticing the n-word and this this that
very high on Twitter guess what do you
know what it was it was 1500 fake Bots
doing all those things and then look how
dropped immediately done because people
said because he said eight bucks a month
those fake Bots gradually disappear so
1500 accounts did those 10 million dirty
tweets to get him to be looked at as
this is a guy that's using all these
n-words LeBron James I'm concerned with
what's going on with Twitter and all
this oh okay yeah these are things that
people fall for and look at how hate
speech is right now at the lowest it's
been since before he bought it obviously
During the period since he bought it
it's dropped back down so a lot of the
noise maybe Kevin on what you're saying
with all this hate that started and now
what happened four years ago with
Atlanta Georgia and all these movies
with the folks at Chick-fil-A we're
gonna see what's gonna happen whether
the dust settles or whether Tim Cook and
Apple's gonna go after and targeting
these guys because of China no one knows
the reason why there may be a
possibility of that happening this is a
story from Fox Business Apple restricts
airdrop file sharing in China that
protests have been used you know what
the timeline is under the latest
software update iOS 16.1.1 iPhone owners
in China can only use airdrop to receive
files images and videos from none other
non-contacts for 10 minutes according to
nine to five Mac
protests I intensified in China after
fire at Residential Building in the
western city of Europe left 10 people
dead uh until they welded the door one
shot yeah once that 10 minute window
lapses airdrop shifts back to contacts
only automatically
is that 10 minutes period or 10 minutes
at a time look at the power
10 minutes at a time meaning you have a
break it's like 10 minutes you can't do
another one so if I'm sitting there like
airdropping just look what happened look
what happened look what happened look
what happened no no no every 10 minutes
every 10 minutes prevents things from
going viral and other people seeing it I
mean so listen China's showing the game
to its people in China and photoshopping
and and editing sites that's showing
people not wearing masks at the freaking
world cup World Cup so people have to
really realize what's going on with this
country they don't believe in what you
and I believe in and when I say you and
I I don't mean you and I politically 95
of people the way you live your life
China's government doesn't believe you
ought to live your life the way you're
living your life you don't share common
values and principles they don't think
highly of us they don't think we're the
freedom and all that stuff that we stand
for and we fight for they don't they
don't stand for that stuff well the
government of China certainly believes
in capitalism but they rule their people
under the you know the banner of
Communism but they they they love making
money and gaining power over the
financial gains they've given not only
from America but from all over the world
so uh you know you talk about the shadow
Banner you got of on Tick Tock I mean
I've got it on Facebook before they took
me down and that's what they do I mean
they all said I was getting a million
views and it's down to 500 then it was
down to a hundred thousand is down to
50. I mean it was just like you could
see it happening right before my eyes
and I'm going wow so so much for freedom
of speech and I think we've never had
total freedom of speech in this country
anyway it's just gotten worse yeah I I
don't know if it happened to us on any
other I think I've not I've I myself
can't say any of that has happened on
any other apps personally except for
tick tock I I see everything else was
about competing and I know what has
happened to other people and I know a
lot of people like yourself that stuff
was taken down viewership went down Etc
et cetera but I haven't seen it happen
with us even YouTube Some people are
like well Pat let me tell you your
Shadow band on Twitter on YouTube I
don't agree I don't think it is I think
we have to fight in the marketplace to
get the message out there I'm very
confident competing with other people on
YouTube totally get it our content's got
to get better we got to get better but
with Tick Tock comparing to other apps
it's very obvious that there's one word
you can use with Tick Tock and you
cannot criticize China on Tick Tock you
just can't you know how they say uh the
pen is mightier than the sword right
well these days social media is the
ultimate pen right I mean that's where
you can express anything you want to say
thoughts emojis memes videos you know
all that I had a a very enlightening
experience at this Freedom Forum Gary
Kasparov greatest chess player ever
spoke at the Vault a year ago invited me
down to the freedom forum and at the
freedom Forum it's all just massive
Freedom Advocates right from all over
the world you know China Chinese uyghurs
and uh you know Iranian uh the lady
forgive me her name with the hair the
one who's uh everywhere these days just
just complete Advocates of freedom and
uh the the most poignant example was
um they set up a like a booth like a
like a massive Booth probably the size
of this room and they called it the
firewall Cafe and basically
um it's sort of exposed what
the Chinese narrative like if you type
something like let's do an example right
now in Google if you type in uh she
president XI and Winnie the Pooh right
because people say he kind of looks like
that whatever this will pop up right I
don't know if you can if you can uh see
that just stupid images right like have
you even put in Trump you know images
will pop up but in this Chinese firewall
the firewall Cafe if you put that in
into the internet in China no images of
Winnie the Pooh will show up whatsoever
so the way that they just basically
segregate any type of content that would
be alarming or or of anything of
disinformation or anything against the
narrative they show it side by side at
this firewall Cafe and for the first
time I'm like oh wow this is what
America is as much as there's Shadow
Banning and all that in China it's
completely blocked and we're seeing
what's happening now with these riots
and protests and I I don't know where
that is nothing they did in the Top Gun
movie right they made it they Tom Cruise
had a jacket on they had the Taiwan flat
or something it was correct there was a
flag that they disagreed with they had
to go through every single frame and
remove it before they will let the movie
out because they're bowing down what
China is telling them to do because
China owns I think basically half the
movie theaters in America too but that's
a big market for American movies so you
see that the Chinese protests right now
they're they're just holding up a white
piece of paper right like you've seen
this it's just a blank so they can't
sheet of paper right what what is the
significance of that do you know what
that is exactly well they can't write
anything that's against the government
so they just pulled it up as a sign of
saying we are against the government ah
yeah very interesting so so what you're
talking about is clashes in Shanghai as
covet protests flare across China
hundreds of demonstrators and police
clashes in Shanghai and Sunday night as
protests over China's stringent uh
coveted restrictions flared for third
day in spread to several cities in the
wake of deadly apartment fire in the
countries for uh Far West the wave of
civil disobedience is unprecedented and
mainly China by the way did you see what
happened yesterday reporter asks uh uh
Steve Kerr hey so coach what do you
think about what's going on in China
right now with people protesting and
asking for Freedom he says oh I don't
know I don't see you ask me questions
about America where somebody comes and
holds us down with an AKA with a
semi-automatic weapon how come you don't
ask me those questions I don't see you
doing this and I don't see you doing
that I'm sitting there saying man
because the NBA is paying a salary the
Chinese paying us there's no question
about it so you're that's the stuff that
they do which by the way that kind of
stuff will go viral on Tick Tock because
they love when America Americans
criticize Americans sure of course they
love if you want to blow up on Tick Tock
let me give you a game plan go on Tick
Tock as an American and trash Americans
trash marriage trash uh you know a
strong Traditional Values trash
Traditional Values trash any of that
stuff and watch how all of a sudden you
blow up on Tick Tock because tick tock's
algorithms will favor you trashing any
of the western philosophies they love
that that stuff is tick tocks bread and
butter if you do that well it's pretty
crazy what's happening all at the same
time right obviously we remember what
happened in 2020 in the protests and the
riots and everything and it was you know
media coverage Galore but look what's
happening all over the world right now
if you look at China in these protests
if you look at Iran and these protests
if you look at Russia and these protests
over the war in Ukraine
I mean there these people are what true
definition of courage really looks like
because they know that they go and they
speak against the government they may
never be seen again period okay and
that's the difference between these
types of countries and these
authoritarian regimes and America you
know our friend Vinnie did a a a bit
basically saying you could do literally
anything in America you could talk [ __ ]
against America you could do all sorts
of crazy nonsense you could do this and
that and that and be it a feminist
whatever Nothing's Gonna really happen
to you but you see what's happening like
with the women in Iran basically trying
to just fight for the fact that they
don't want to wear the hijab and what's
the number of 15 000 people are
apparently going to be executed executed
okay Russia they did an expose where you
know they covered the face of these uh
of a group of people and they were
basically talking about do you think
that people are going to really try to
speak up against Putin raise your hand
if you think that that anything will
actually happen nobody raised their hand
no in China you know everyone's wearing
masks I don't think that's necessarily
because of the covet thing because they
want to hide their face right for the
whole social credit score but the
scariest thing ever in these countries
is when a van pulls up
and you're you're the guy you know
protesting and all of a sudden 5 10 cops
just throw you in the van
and that's it yeah where are you going
at that point gone forever and and I
think all of that you're saying is more
of a reason why uh what's happened with
Twitter with Elon Musk is necessary very
much so I think the next move is he's
doing what many concern and he's not
even I wouldn't even put him as a
conservative I don't think he's a
conservative Elon Musk I don't think no
it's not I put Elon Musk as a
Libertarian fiscally conservative guy is
what I put him as he's not a Christian
he's not a I don't see him as a guy
that's gonna you know sitting out there
saying you need to go to church and pray
I don't see that as a mosque I don't see
any of that stuff I think he's a very
very one of those Minds that's just
thinking things in a different thinker
yeah but but but at the same time but at
the same time he's doing what
Republicans and conservatives didn't do
the last 30 years the Republicans and
conservatives lost a war for
universities for every one conservative
Professor 13 liberals you lost a war of
media you lost a war of newspapers you
lost a war of what else you want you
lost the war of movies you lost the war
of Hollywood you lost the war of
persuasion you lost the war of virtual
governments you've lost the war and the
first Victory they've had in many years
as a guy who's not even a conservative
buys
Twitter says I think speech should be
free that's it and here's what I want to
do so there should be more examples of
that somebody needs to buy the next Hulu
the next any of those things and start
competing in the Hollywood space now
obviously
you have guys on the uh uh on the
current uh conservative side like the
folks at the uh Chick-fil-A that are
investing into it and they build a
massive I think the the campus they
built is uh the studio they build is
massive I've seen videos of it I've seen
pictures of it oh yeah what they have oh
yeah I mean they they're and like I can
totally they're completely booked for
the next couple years and filming movies
completely the book Chick-fil-A campus
yeah wow yeah that's one of the crusade
of what they have well to compete in the
Hollywood Marketplace this was my
question for you for Elon back to to
Twitter number one I don't think this is
my opinion
Twitter as it currently exists just
being sort of the platform where you can
just you know what is it 120 characters
whatever it is as is uh is a
is the type of business model or type of
app that's going to blow up meaning I
totally agree with what Tyler's
basically saying that if he turns it
into a a WeChat type of thing where it's
this all all-in-one encompassing type of
app where you can bank and get an Uber
and all that kind of stuff I think
that's the future of Twitter I don't
think it has a sustainable as is right
now but that's one point here's my
question to you Pat
how many companies is Elon Musk running
at this point right between obviously
Twitter Tesla space asks neural link
starlink the boring company the tunnel
company that he does
um open AI I'm just these are things
that are coming to mind sure how does he
what kind of bandwidth neurolink what
kind of bandwidth do you need to have
him you're a guy who's running multiple
companies I see how much
how you're divvy up your schedule like I
have a hard time just balancing two
companies plus a personal life how does
someone like Elon Musk balance all of
this
I think a long time ago he chose career
over like priority in life to him he
feels his cause is more worthy of him
going up against these types of enemies
versus I don't know if father is number
one on his list I don't know if husband
is number one on his list I don't know
if those things are number one on his
list I think he seems himself as a
warrior Crusader genius he's building
what he's building he does believe in
procreation because he's got a lot of
kids he's got like 10 kids or something
so so his his kids are his businesses so
if you treated your businesses as your
kids because kids are very taxing
they're very demanding so if you have
four kids and you got four businesses it
is very hard to race four kids it is
very hard to race four businesses you
have to kind of pick and choose which
one you're going to be doing he says
he's at the office seven days a week 18
hours a day 24 hours a day he's sleeping
there what he's saying is I'm also not
spending time with the kids I'm spending
time my kids that's Twitter that's this
that's that so yeah you can do that if
you choose to treat your companies like
your kids and that's what he's doing but
you're basically sacrificing a
relationship with your kids everything
in life you're gonna have to at one
point uh uh on a when you're on a run of
obsession you're sacrificing all these
athletes we admire that you follow Kobe
Bryant's sacrifice personal time with
his family 20 years of playing 82 games
41 on the road playoffs Olympics you
think that's a peaceful life military
generals General Mattis we admire
35-year service you know he's in you
know War for you think you're you're a
good father I haven't seen my kid nine
years out of the last 18 years my kid
was you know at the house I was at War I
was on you think that's you put that as
a great father what do you how do you
describe that so the definition of all
of these things it's very to him his
mind is if these generals are at War
doing what they're doing I'm simply
doing my war in business competing
against these guys and I see my kids
where I take them place and we have a
good time but I'm like like the general
that's at War I don't see my kids for a
year and a half or a year I see myself
same as that I think that's his
processing and I don't think he sees
anything wrong with that and I think a
lot of people that have competed at that
level at that crazy level say yeah
that's what you got to do you know when
you're running for office like John F
Kennedy ran for office when he was how
old early 40s what do you think his life
looked like he was the youngest
president no 43 how old was the guy when
he became president not on 42 40 42 43
youngest ever because I mean the Obama
and Clinton are right behind him right
right at 47 or 40 or something like that
what do you think you're doing when
you're campaigning for two years
you you don't think your kids in second
grade he has kids that are under his
desk the pictures those are not 20 year
old kids these are you know what do you
think it is when your Hollywood star
Denzel Washington you're going out there
doing movies where this guy was in
Sicily for uh how long were you in
Sicily shooting uh three weeks okay
that's three weeks away from 17 19 and a
20 year old yeah that's a that's not you
know so these these types of performers
at that level there comes with a
sacrifice but the the the average person
will look at that and say oh my gosh
that's terrible but the peak Peak
performers at the top will sit there and
say yeah that's kind of what you got to
do it's by the way neither side can sell
it to the other side it's purely a
choice
neither side can sell it to the other
side and that's a great point I think on
behalf of Americans and behalf of
humanity I think we're all thankful that
he is sacrificing his family life but
you know you do see these stories that
one of his kids came out and disowned
his father and he's not my father and he
might be some sort of trans situation
with one of the kids I don't know what
that story is but you're familiar with
the story right one of the kids
basically disavowed so these are the
types of sacrifices you're making that
your kids won't even love you or they'll
disapp value or disown you because you
have such lofty goals that there is you
know risks and rewards to everything
you're doing well in my defense we're
homeschool Advocates so when I use when
I go on the road the kids always travel
certainly when they're younger you know
when they're my daughter's only one left
in school now at 17. my other 18 year
old just graduated my 21 year olds you
know doing his own thing too but growing
up they were always on the road with me
so that made a big difference and that's
what uh wasn't the reason we did
homeschooling we did homeschooling
because our Public School Systems sucked
and my wife wanted to do it so uh
um yeah this that's her book right there
right there your kids but it's um she's
a homeschool Advocate travels the
country doing it and I think for us it
worked out quite great so I was with my
kids quite a bit of the day Kudos yeah
Kudos made a big and I'm assuming you
guys are all close to each other oh look
the whole family oh yeah yeah very much
that takes a lot of work by the way when
you say that about elon's kids yeah uh
realized that on the conservative side
the best president they'll look at the
last hundred years is who who is the
Reagan okay so if you look at Reagan as
the best president his oldest biological
son
and the son that he bapped that he
adopted Michael Reagan yeah 100 is loyal
to Ronald Reagan as his uh uh father so
you know there's a risk with parenting
there's because all it takes is for one
kid to say that one time you said this
and then for the rest of their lives
they will go up against anything you say
they want to do the opposite there's
risk it's a very very tough job being a
parent is very risky very risky Kevin
can I ask you a question regarding your
books and homeschooling so you know no
secret that public schools especially I
mean in Miami here like you know
especially High School not exactly um
the best play right there but why do you
choose homeschooling over private school
like Pat has done a very very hardcore
vetting process so if you Biz DOC for
the types of schools he wants his kids
to go to right Pat I mean you you've
gone through this process and you've
chosen the best of the best private
schools because a you can afford it but
B because they teach the values and
principles that you want your kids
learning for sure what made you go down
the homeschool path rather than the
private school well I grew up Minnesota
I had friends who are doing it or write
buddies that they got kids they got
married in their 20s I got married in my
30s so there's a whole different Road
for me but they were homeschooling their
kids and so there's a lot of questions I
had about that as well and I saw the way
their kids turned out the kids are
awesome and they're great with adults
they're great with you know they don't
have to go through the ridiculous
bullying and the whole click thing and
stuff like that and they're awesome with
everybody and I see that with my kids as
well my wife just said my oldest at the
time was in second grade and we thought
we were in a better school district
because we were out of L.A County we're
up in Ventura county in California we're
supposed to be you know more
conservative more better same problems
in those schools as well my wife said
enough of this she goes I'm gonna dive
into this and she talked to the friends
that I knew that we're homeschooling and
she just went for it full on and she is
like a hardcore homeschool Advocate
travels the country this is one of books
right there on it and she speaks across
the country constantly on it and
actually she's speaking at Mar-A-Lago
this this weekend about homeschooling
there too is there like Obama putting an
event over there or at marlago uh not
Obama's not now
I thought maybe Obama he probably won't
be there but anyway just curious um I'd
love to tell you my meeting with him one
time
um but Obama oh yeah but um it was it
was it was just something that for us
worked really well and also for the
travel that we did with it it just it
just made more sense and one thing one
blessing of covet you mentioned with one
thing about covet
um people started waking up to see how
horrible our school system is because it
sucks I don't know what we rank
worldwide the 27th in the world it's
something pretty bad right now and
um
when when uh we we dove into this we
were just happy to be part of it covet
good Lord two million more kids now are
being homeschooled because people said
enough of this enough using public
schools as a babysitting service for our
kids look what's going on in our schools
and then you know the whole Mass wearing
of kids too that just cracked me up and
fouchy did you see what he said somebody
asked him about do you know the origin
of this now can we finally figure that
out and then they asked oh he wouldn't
talk about that then they asked about
the mask wearing thing and he said I'm
not here to cover such trivialities I'm
here to say people's lives okay yes
that's what you're for the greatest war
criminal probably ever in the history of
America but I think that's another story
and he came back and he admitted that
there is a deleterious effect on the
nation's kids because of the lockdown in
terms of the educational development
that happened there and so he came out
and said it but then he said but don't
blame me for it it's not my fault it's
like come on dude come on dude yeah
y'all want amnesty I don't think history
is going to favor uh a guy very well
because no it's just not going to happen
with that guy there's going to be
eventually a movie we're going to watch
and you're going to sit there and say
wow what a dirty guy I think a lot of
people are going to say that about him
they're trying to protect him because he
helped them get rid of somebody in
office that none of them liked and uh
the swamp didn't like I had a couple
guys here on the podcast last week on
the JFK uh uh 59 year anniversary of his
assassination
one of them was James the Eugenio and
another one was another fellow that we
had on have a hard time pronouncing his
last name Gregory something David
Montague David Montague and we had one
two other people one of them was uh uh
uh ernestovitz and both of them were
best Paul Gregory yeah Paul Gregory both
of them were best friends with the
shooter Oswald one in Russia and the
other one in Fort Worth and they were
best friends so it's very interesting
kind of I've always been fascinated
about this JFK assassination and then
obviously he's a staunch Democrat
supporter of John F Kennedy all this
stuff who would be a republican today
who would be a republican yeah
listen to his 1960 inauguration speech
so James D Eugenio is sitting here and I
really enjoy talking to him because I've
had Oliver Stone as well and Oliver
Stone also big JFK neither one of them
like Trump I said who killed JFK is it
fair to say that the swamp killed JFK he
said yeah I said uh who do you think
killed Trump in a different way also the
swamp a
a stock they can't say anything I said
so do two have a lot in common no no
there's not even close they're this I
said John F Kennedy was part of the NRA
he was a proud NRA card member this guy
was a second amendment guy this guy was
lowering the taxes guy this guy what are
you talking about what this guy stood
for so I think you know where we're
going today with all the you know things
that we're facing and seeing what's
going on guys like this history is not
going to favor guys like this he's going
to be exposed I can't wait to watch the
movie I'd be so curious to know who ends
up playing him uh an older version of
him I think Joe Pesci could pull it off
but I don't know maybe somebody else
could play him to uh see what this guy's
story is all about everybody I've spoken
to that's worked closely with him uh
back in the days in the 80s uh he was
always a very ambitious guy but I
haven't heard a lot of good things about
this guy I think they're gonna do a
movie they will do a movie on Monte
you're right about Joe's been a friend
for 35 years he's just shut up and he's
a conservative and he didn't want to go
do the Irishman but he got talked into
it and went there in DeNiro every day
was the best and Trump and they he just
kind of went back and forth with them
saying what is wrong with you why are
you such a child about this you know so
uh it is interesting with Trump because
I keep asking my liberal friends what
policies did you not like of his they
can't name policy I just hate his ego
did you like the fact we're energy
independent do you like the fact that
black and and Hispanic uh unemployment
Lois ever we had a safe border I mean
it's amazing to me how they just feed
into this you know media frenzy just to
go after the guy because he wasn't a he
wasn't a DC guy he was a guy that went
in there as a business guy and said the
country needs to be fixed and I agree
with guys like that we need more people
to run this country that aren't
politicians now I mean that's a great
transition into what just happened this
last week Washington examiner page nine
I'll read the story with uh uh musk
coming out and saying how uh Elon Musk
says he will be back uh Trump rivalry he
will back around that run the centers in
2024 she signal he would be a place uh
his support behind Ron DeSantis should
he choose to challenge president Donald
Trump to be a republican nominee for the
White House he made the comment in
response to a question from a Twitter
user asking if he would vote for
DeSantis to test on Twitter CEO reminded
users that he was a significant
supporter for the Obama Administration
he said in the threat that he
reluctantly voted for Joe Biden over
Trump in 2020 and seemingly regrets it
my preference for 2024 presidency is
someone sensible and Centrist I hope
that would be the case for the Biden
Administration but have been
disappointed so far musk first suggested
he was leaning towards supporting the
Florida governor in June when he was
asked by Twitter user for from whom he
would like to support in 2024 responded
DeSantis he prefers the comment by
saying it it would still be determined
whether he would end up voting
Republican or not but this story happens
uh and then you get this weekend uh
somebody shows up at mar-lago
unannounced uh what's his name let me
see what page the story is on Kanye West
what pictures
those guys show up right at the bottom
of the same page if you were just
reading page nine is it bottom of page
nine yeah this is a f and Nightmare
Donald Trump's team scrambling after the
former president's controversial dinner
with uh white supremacist Nick Fuentes a
member of Donald Trump's team is calling
the former president's dinner with Kanye
West and renowned white supremacist and
Holocaust the United nikuentes a f a
nightmare as they scramble to run damage
control for his 2024 campaign uh the
source who served as a long-time advisor
to the embattled politician chose to
remain anonymous avoiding anger in him
or being thought of as disloyal anyways
what'd you think about the whole visit
from Nick Fuentes and uh Kanye West
going to Mar-A-Lago what are your
thoughts on them
um honestly I didn't I this is the first
time I heard of this so I don't know if
I have anything worthwhile even talk
about okay I don't know what do you
think about it
look
um
this was not a good look for Donald
Trump okay so
um
Trump's been known that if someone likes
me I like them right like that's sort of
his thing if he says nice things about
me I like them now right but this was
the exact opposite of a positive
direction for Trump I mean the the
bottom line is you have people
that were so staunchly in his Camp you
see what Ann Coulter just said no Ann
Coulter was if you recall of course the
first person
she was the first person
they laughed her off stage everyone oh
you dumb [ __ ] you don't know nothing it
turns out she was right right she is now
basically saying I am so done with this
guy read the news Ann coulter's saying
this then you've got
you know the whole Fox Murdoch situation
Murdoch's done with him right there's
this Groundswell of people just saying
like look man you've done some good
stuff you've done some bad stuff
time to exit stage left when I say that
I don't mean like the 30 of America that
is his staunch base sure I mean everyone
else and that's the problem in this
country right now is that 30 of the
country look right here right wing Pond
and colder just misses Ronald Trump says
he's so dumb and you've got the
mcconnels of the world and you've got
the bill bars of the world and the VP
Mike Pence of the world all basically
saying look Don thank you for everything
we're kind of over you and then who's
everybody you know the latest uh flavor
of the day is everybody's on DeSantis
right now and for this isn't even my
opinion who cares what Adam has to say I
don't think he's the flavor of the day I
think he's growing because of his
performance as a governor through that
let's be fair with that correct but the
the reason why he's in the National
media is because he's the counterpart or
the the better alternative to Trump
that's sort of how the media is
portraying him but forget about what
Adam thinks forget about Republicans
think what you need to focus on is what
Independents think we all we all just
saw what happened in the midterms you
know Republicans are supposed to run
away with this thing were they not like
it was supposed to be a bloodbath what
they call it a red wave it was like a
red teardrop because
Independence broke overwhelmingly for
the Democrats and if you want to win in
this country we say this is still
shocking to me well but but here's my
point if your boat was counted don't be
shocked if it happens again right and if
if you want to like for me but how bad
does it have to get I mean under under
Biden how bad does the country have to
get for somebody to go I don't know I'm
not really in like the complaining
business I'm in like the just looking at
the facts business
right now they just did polling like do
you want Trump to run again 80 of
Republicans said yes 90 of Democrats
said no right obviously clear but 60 of
Independents said no that's the number
you need to look at so if he loses don't
be like well what don't you get it we're
in energy independent there's this
clamoring for basically Americans saying
thank you so much
please exit stage left so if he loses
again in 2024 because he'll likely get
the nomination unless there's something
goes terribly wrong you already have the
answer there but back to the Nick
Fuentes thing I don't know Nick Fuentes
you know I don't know much of his
content but we talked about a narrative
we talked about the narrative even when
we talked about Patrick Mahomes the
other day like his narrative is he's
going to win the big game and that's
exactly what happened when he played
against the Chargers The Narrative of
this guy Nick Fuentes is that he's a
white nationalist and a holocaust denier
so that's the type of person that you're
having at Mar-A-Lago and there's no
vetting process so just Kanye shows up
like hey Kanye here not sure if you've
heard what I'm doing in the news these
days but pretty much hate the Jews
trying to go Defcon 3 on the Jews by the
way I'm gonna bring a holocaust denier
with me we're gonna hang out with you
for a little while Trump yeah okay and
now Trump's walking this back and last
point I said you my friend that I've
referenced all the time he's the biggest
Trump Maga guy in my life Joe you know
I'm talking about him he texted me the
other day he goes I'm officially done
with Donald Trump I said what are you
talk like when I say Kevin if you think
you're a hardcore Trump supporter he's
going to make you look like a woke
liberal that's how hardcore he is he
said yeah I can no longer support this
guy who's basically hanging around with
Holocaust deniers yeah uh so that this
is when you're losing guys like that
that's not a good sign
yeah let me read you what Trump said
here so I help a seriously troubled man
who just happened to be black yay Kanye
West who has been decimated in his
business and virtually everything else
and it has always been good to me by
allowing his requests for meeting at
Mar-A-Lago alone so that I can give him
very much needed advice he shows up with
three people two of which I don't know
the other political person who I haven't
seen in years I told them don't run for
office a total waste of time can't win
fake news went viral went crazy so
that's the response now you know
um
but he's so he's calling Kanye troubled
great and and by the way Kanye was on
Temple yesterday right was it yesterday
or day before yeah he walked off he
walked up because I'm talking [ __ ] about
Jews again yeah he walked off within the
first 10 minutes and who was on it Milo
was on it and Nick was on it so that's
the crew the three of them that are
together going around talking about what
they're talking about I don't know look
here's here's a couple things that is
not a good idea in the marketplace
whether you like it or not you're going
to be judged by who's around you okay if
that's how it is in business that's how
it is in sports that's how it is in
everything you do if you come up and say
your campaign is you Milo and Nick
Fuentes I had a meeting with Milo once
six years ago five years ago I don't
know what timeline it was I was I don't
know I was in Orlando or somewhere like
that and we met up uh and we had a
conversation together about his father I
want to say I think we even have a video
we never went live with it uh about his
upbringing house relationship was what
is that that's where my curiosity was
with Milo I don't know who Nick is but
for a trump you gotta know who's coming
to your place and you got to filter
those people out and for Kanye you know
you wanted to run at a time like this
and you're going around uh walking off
of sets anytime somebody walks off a set
I I don't know if that's showing any
kind of strength with where you're at it
wasn't a good look did you actually see
the podcast on what happened what led to
him getting off like did you watch the
whole thing yeah I watched I watched the
clip of walking I'll see him walking up
no I didn't get a chance to see it I
don't know uh
but so we're talking about a couple
different things here but all the stars
are aligning with Kanye this guy Nick
Fuentes coming to Trump so it just seems
to me like if we can go to Kanye for a
second
like what is he trying to prove here
like okay you have a beef with certain
people in the music space or in the
business world who happen to be Jewish
believe me I'm Jewish it's not like I'm
getting these phone calls to to discuss
uh Kanye's label it's not all Jews are
painted in this broad brush these are
these people you're doing business with
and the reason you're doing business
with them is because they probably
invented the company like they forgot
that Jews you might know this better
than me Kevin invented Hollywood they
invented Stanley it's not like they just
were plucked out all right Jews you run
it the Warner Brothers they started the
business shout out to Brian Callan for
informing me of all this stuff but like
you're like what's your beef what's your
point you you want to expose the people
that started the company that happened
to be the people that that you have a
beef with but so Kanye
you know if there's anything I can say
about Kanye musical genius no doubt but
we talked about his blind spots
narcissist not able to just basically
heed advice who's in your ear stuff that
we talk about all the time here but
you're basically saying yeah I've got
myself in all this hot water whether you
agree with it or not he's in hot water
and you're saying let me go bring this
white Christian nationalist
white supremacists what he's labeled as
Nick Fuentes around with me everywhere
now let me take them to Mar-A-Lago and
and destroy my relationship with Trump
let me bring him on podcasts and
basically and if you're this guy Nick
Fuentes and Connie wants to take you all
around what are you gonna say
of course he loves the world sign me up
bro my name's all over the back but I
tell you I tell you I tell you one thing
as well and there are certain labels
that that hurts it's career ending
labels just so you know uh uh
anti-semite you know racist a white
supremacist a white nationalist a pedo a
at any of this yes right these labels
are uh being dropped a Nazi they bring
and dropped left and right and you just
a big it these are very powerful labels
that people put on you it's an
incredible strategy to do with anybody
because immediately 99 of people who
don't know who that guy is they're gonna
be like oh that's that's what he is done
I'm moving on
misogynist don't I'm not talking to
YouTube yeah this doesn't have to be
proof at all yeah so so to me in that
part I've never watched a single piece
of content of Nick I have not how many
times have you guys brought him up
potentially somebody to have on the
podcast
right it's coming his name's come up for
you I'm like guys I I haven't seen
anything to see so I can't make an
educated decision on where he's at all I
know is as a person that tries to
do his best as an emotional being to
process with reason uh I have to sit
there and reason uh on who he is I don't
know him yet so I can't jump to
conclusion and say he is that or he's
not that okay
uh people change but Connie is strategy
on how he's communicating there is a
risk when you take a position and you
put it out there Trump took a risk when
he said the borders all these people are
coming across their rapists they're this
they're that Max that that that
statement came with a lot of risk and it
was on him the next six to 12 months to
sell everybody on why that's a risk and
an American said okay yeah let me tell
you why we need to build a wall and
first reaction everybody's like what
yeah with China's got a wall this way
why can't we have a wall you live in a
house Nancy Pelosi's got a gated
community with walls around her house so
let me get this straight it's okay for
people to build a wild house around a
wall against their house but it's not
okay to build a wall against your
country what's wrong with that such and
such Doesn't and you're like oh wow okay
voter ID Mexico does voter ID why can't
we do voter ID no no you're like oh so
these are things that you have to sell
and Kanye hasn't done a good job selling
that's all there's to it if he was a
better salesperson of the controversial
argument he made then the audience would
say oh okay that's you know what
fine that's a that's a good point he's
not been able to sell this point your
job as a campaigner is to sell a point
for others to say that makes sense that
hasn't happened to enough people yet
can I tell you why I agree with you
wholeheartedly yeah on on the labels
right so like you've worked your ass off
to be like if you put in Patrick David
or if someone wants to like if the media
wants to write something about Patrick
but David they're going to say
entrepreneur Patrick Bet David said
actor Kevin Sorbo said blah blah blah
blah look at the look at the uh Outlet
right here right wing pundit and Coulter
says this is who you are okay we're all
creating ourselves and maybe if you're
lucky enough you get labeled what you
actually are right so when Kanye West
who's been known as rapper Kanye West
for 20 plus years is now
anti-semitic rapper Kanye West he's
earned that label so when this guy Nick
Fuentes is labeled as white supremacist
Holocaust denier Nick Fuentes I'm sorry
these labels a lot of times are who you
are or they're basically you're not
going to shed these labels like Tom has
done a good job being known as The Biz
doc why because he's literally a doctor
of business for the last 20 something
years because he's earned that right you
know so the link can a long time said
don't believe everything you read on the
internet right and he was a big he was a
very active on Twitter can you pull up
Patrick by David Height please just
Google Patrick with David height this is
my favorite when you type in Patrick by
David height okay go and zoom in a
little bit zoom in a little bit one day
no no zoom in a little bit first so we
can see it okay so watch it's on that
website I'm five seven okay on this
other website I'm five five okay on this
website I'm five seven
on that other website I'm again five
seven crazy so I'm either five two five
five five seven on on Google how awesome
is it in real life you're six four which
is incredible but
that's another one says five feet seven
inches at 154 pounds how the hell do you
find that
154 pounds it was a picture of you and
me standing together and they said
Patrick
so so you have a point there that
obviously don't believe everything you
say out there but the reality is if you
like
according to the internet how many
people say to me I thought you were five
seven I'm like why didn't you think I
was five seven well because of the
internet
no doubt you can't just read everything
at face value here but no you you
everyone works very hard to have a
reputation
and how about we talk about balenciaga's
reputation is that okay we're talking
about their reputation
my wife the wife is watching right now
go for it I missed them I missed a
moment on homeschooling she says it's
risky to send your kids to public
schools because you're sending your
children away from you to be
indoctrinated against you every day by
the way what's your wife's name what's
Sam Sam I fully agree with you I had a
meeting exactly pastor this last week I
said the fact that churches are not
fully packed right now tells you pastors
are not selling their message properly
today I had I had a conversation with a
couple guys the other you know what I
said I said listen and I know this is
going to go against a lot of
non-denomination I'm a non-denomination
myself the message was I don't care if
you're a Christian Catholic seven day
LDS a Jew I don't care what you are get
your kids to go to church today because
at least the conservative values are
being taught there's never been more if
you can't afford or private school if
you can't afford a homeschooling you
can't afford to take your kids to a
local church and get them involved kids
need a lot more now don't get me wrong I
know people are going to come back and
say look what happened to the Catholic
church and all this other stuff totally
get it I understand what you're saying
all I'm saying to you is in a controlled
fashion get your kids around learning
solid values the kids are needing that
more because public schools are
definitely not teaching that today
anyways let's talk about this Balenciaga
story uh Kim Kardashian says she's
disgusted by the Balenciaga holiday ad
campaign that's been accused of sexual
sexualization of minors if you want to
pull this up so we can read what she
says there's a
Twitter a thread that goes up uh she
says the following uh I'm gonna pull
this up here I have been quiet for the
past few days not because I have uh I
haven't been discussing and outraged by
the recent Balenciaga campaigns but
because I wanted an opportunity to speak
to their team to understand for myself
how this could have happened as a mother
of four I have been shaken by the
disturbing images the safety of children
must be held with the highest regards
and any attempt to normalize child abuse
of any kind should have no place in our
society I appreciate balenciaga's
removal of the campaign and apology and
speaking with them I believe they
understand the seriousness of the issue
and will take the necessary measures for
this to never happen again as for my
future of a Balenciaga I'm currently
reevaluating my relationship with the
brand basing it off their willingness to
accept accountability for something they
should have never happened to begin with
and the actions I'm expecting to see
them take to protect children so now
this is what Kim says this is how
Balenciaga response and tell me if
you're comfortable with this Balenciaga
files a 25 million dollar lawsuit
against producers of the controversial
BDSM teddy bear ad campaign balenciagas
filed a 25 million lawsuit the fashion
house brought the suit Friday against
the production company North 6 Inc and
the set designer Nicholas Des the
Jordans and his uh eponymous company for
the inclusion in one of the ads of legal
documents from a U.S Supreme Court
decision on child porn loss the fashion
brand ad also showed unsettling pictures
of a child holding teddy bears dressed
in bondage outfits the two-page courts
summons doesn't mention the BDSM teddy
bears Balenciaga is bringing a case to
seek uh redress for extensive damages
defendants cause in the connection with
an advertising campaign balancing a
hired from them to produce the Manhattan
supreme court summons alleges Balenciaga
claims North 6.
and this Jordans included the images of
the Court docks without its knowledge
which was malevent or at the very least
extraordinarily Reckless the filing
States let me get this straight we've
hired a lot of different marketing firms
here's how marketing firms work with us
okay
so
back in the days pre-social like when I
hadn't started a YouTube this is 2010
2000 I don't have a Twitter account I
don't have any of that stuff I'm not
doing anything I don't have a YouTube
account I started YouTube I think
December of 2012 2013 is when we started
so I hired this marketing agency and
they come in and they say we should do
this a marketing agent you pay them the
money they present you the product the
video the commercial whatever maybe and
then you say no and then from there you
give them access if they're using your
Twitter account you give them access if
they're using your Instagram Instagram
account you give them access to all your
social a marketing company doesn't come
and post anything on your Instagram
account without your permission
Balenciaga so unless if this marketing
company came in with a gun put to your
head at the board meeting saying give us
all your passwords let us post this with
the following and let you get some
backlash no this 25 billion dollar
lawsuit is not the marketing's company
you agreed for this thing to be posted
you get 100 of the responsibility stop
thinking people are dumb there's not a
single marketing firm agency in America
that comes and having access to all your
password to post this this was a hundred
percent your responsibility and the most
naive person in America who runs or
works for marketing agency has called
[ __ ] in your strategy here to defend
your position that you had with this you
screwed up royally oh completely and by
the way this is a smoke screen this is
is complete BS because the production
company has approvals that have to be at
all these checkpoints all these sign
offs hey what do you think what do you
think what do you think what do you
think they don't move without signatures
because that's how they get paid so this
is a smoke screen they are suing these
guys and it's going to get tossed
because these guys are going to go Oh
you mean these approvals and this
summary of what the photo shoot was
going to be that was signed off by the
chief marketing officer and this here
and the three people from the companies
that were there who believes that this
was an accident
no I don't think I I hope any sensible
person doesn't believe in the accent but
my point is this suit's going to get
tossed quickly and this is a smoke
screen for Balenciaga temporary
nothing's going to court nothing big
legal dollars aren't going to be spent
except on filing fees because the court
is going to toss us this is just them
protecting their butt that's all this is
so so this is what do you think about
this I'm suing someone so it's better I
I agree I mean this is just the way to
cover themselves and say I had no idea
about this of course they had an idea
about it you're not spending the kind of
money they're spending with these people
and not being included in what they're
doing looking at Daily yes they were oh
isn't this cute yeah it's cute it's
great it's like don't look over here
don't don't look at us over here we
don't want to accept change the lighting
give me more purple yeah
it's uh yeah I don't think he has
anything to stand on you're right this
would be thrown out immediately but you
know you know what I would think is what
the marketing agency is going to say
like say say you're the marketing agency
you're listening to this let's just say
you're that marketing agency you
presented this to them
a marketing agency comes in asks a ton
of questions
the brand tells you what they're looking
for for example let me tell you what
kind of a commercial we want to make we
want to make a commercial where think
about the story I want a voice of God
telling the story of how Jeep uh
Cherokee uh and and how the hard-working
American man I want it to be a deep
voice to tell the story and then we show
how America has been so great on what
it's done and how the creators the hard
workers the steel workers we want that
kind of an image and then a marketing
company goes and creates that commercial
for you that's how commercials are made
just so you know well this is going to
hurt the marketing agency as well this
is gonna be another portfolio who wants
to hire these guys at this kind of ideas
they're coming up with I I but I don't
put the onus on the market DJ our Dean
he's just gonna
all I know is uh you're gonna see how
long this is gonna last look a story
came out which is kind of weird but I
don't know when you read a story like
this it's kind of weird page two about
page three by California uh and this
kind of goes with this thousands of
convicted pedophiles in California are
being released from prison in less than
a year
pedophiles are getting less than a year
prison time after a range of horrific
acting including rapes raping kids under
14 a daily mail.com investigation
reveals analysis of a California
database of sex offenders shows
thousands of child molesters are being
let out after just a few months despite
sentencing guidelines current and former
sex crimes prosecutors said the figures
are terrifying and shameful more than
seven thousand sex offenders were
convicted of lewd or uh uh uh uh
lascivious acts with a child under 14
years of age but were LED out of prison
the same year they were incarcerated
data from California Megan's Law
database databases
the way California is being ran right
now which which story yeah we'll finish
with that what are your thoughts about
the story with California does it
surprise you I mean we're letting people
attack people with higher irons and
baseball bats and let them out at the
same day it's like you bring them in you
let them out I mean what's going on in
that state what you can steal a thousand
dollars or less than a thousand dollars
worth of 20 24 Walgreens or something in
San Francisco close down yeah because
people are going in every day stealing
thousands I mean tens of thousands how
do you stay in business and at the
elderly in California are so careless
they leave the door unlocked guys can
then hit you with a hammer
have you uh do you still live in
California no I left four years ago I
live here we live in Florida we left
before all the coven Madness yeah we we
live in West Palm Beach area we we left
we've been coming out for years we have
family living out here and we've been
looking to go to California for at least
the last 10 years and four years ago we
just finally made the move do you miss
it at all or what do you miss it I loved
I lived in an area called Westlake
Village thousand uh Thousand Oaks it's
between LA and Santa Barbara and I don't
have to decide it's blue beautiful I
missed the house hide there I'll miss
the mountains I've got the ocean here so
I don't miss the ocean but you live in
West Lake yeah
where did you off of Lindero Canyon oh
beautiful yeah by the way do you know do
you know where Westlake is I only know
the office in uh Westlake and like
Westlake is like honestly it's like the
place to be where you have some sort of
privacy and you're off the map it's a
very very cool area West Lake Agora
Hills phenomenal about 45 miles north of
downtown L.A it's fantastic we're there
for 10 years love it I miss my house it
was fantastic but we just got to a point
I said I've shot over 70 movies since my
Hercules and Andromeda years and I would
say 60 of those Texas or further east
nothing shoots in California and I said
why are we paying state tax dealing with
your traffic dealing with attack the
politics of the state but nothing
actually shoots together he had a 70.
all the studios are housed there sitcoms
pretty most part but no they none of the
Toronto Vancouver
um Georgia as I mentioned yeah Atlanta
New Orleans I just shot the Reagan movie
in in Guthrie Oklahoma with Dennis Quaid
gotcha that's coming up so when you see
all these actors like you know Mark
Wahlberg just left I mean I'm not
surprised it's because yeah but as far
as the doing your job right you don't
necessarily need to be in California
Mark Wahlberg could live in anywhere I
don't know why he picked Nevada I think
there's a lot of stuff I mean I had a
home there for many years but
um I just for me it was convenience to
get into La when I needed to get in
there but but uh Wahlberg is probably
looking the same thing I heard he wants
to build a studio out there as well but
we're grateful to be here the movie's
been fantastic and uh I love it here
like I said I've been coming up you live
here in West Lake Village area I mean
that was like West Palm Beach area West
Palm Beach area
we uh originally when we came here we
made offers on homes in uh Manalapan I
like Manalapan a lot Lantana that whole
area we're in Wellington we're in Horse
Country oh I know where you're at we got
we got we got land we got on a lake it's
you're right by King's College is it not
King's College King's College isn't too
far away yeah yeah it's uh you know the
the kid who won the valedictorian two
years ago he gave a speech that went
viral 20 million views the valedictorian
of the school it's a great school we
looked at the campus we got a tour nice
facility and it's in Wellington I want
to say um
yeah it's it's it's probably for where
we live it's probably about 10 miles
yeah but what do you always say about
California I love it here but it's not
worth the 13 point the three percent
which they're about to raise at higher
iron and by the way as much as you say
what you say about California just so
you know Newsom will be the Democratic
nominee of course they were president
because he is a superstar for them
where's the story about U.S against Iran
on the first page uh let's see what we
got going on here so this this game we
got a big game calls for U.S to be
kicked out of the World Cup after
removing Islamic Republic symbol from
the flag social media post the U.S Men's
National Team uh infuriated Iran's uh
officials by briefly using an Iranian
flag that lacked the Islamic Republic
symbol in the center of the banner on
the U.S team's social media World Cup
post the usmnt posted a statement saying
it intended to use it include incomplete
Iranian flag for 24 hours to show our
support for women in Iran wow the US MNT
used a flag to represent Iran in this
world cup social media posts that
appeared solely as a green white and red
stripe Banner deleting the central
symbol of a sword and four curves
representing the saying there is no God
but God the design is also meant to
represent a tulip to or lotus flower the
symbol was created in 1980 by the
Islamic Republic after 1979 mola
Revolution that ousted the Shah of Iran
from Power The Daily Mail reported by
the way the interviews have been epic
the U.S player that was asked by the way
we are not Iranian you know Iranian and
and said well I apologize for the way to
pronounce I will do my best this is a
great thing about progress I've played
for a lot of different teams around the
world what I like about America is that
we're making progress you know the
message
that was good so what's gonna happen
this is a big game this is very good
it's gonna be high scoring another one
zipper
another Thriller and soccer people run
100 meters back and forth they're
calling for Americans to America USA to
be kicked out for what they did with the
flag yes yeah I'm making a prediction uh
the only thing that will be kicked out
is Iran after they lose this game
America wins we move on to the
quarterfinals and Iran will be kicked
out you know how many people
Iran or USA I said get my plug yeah I
will tell you this I will tell you I go
ahead I said one thing I know about Pat
is that he was born in Iran but he was
made in the USA and I assume you're
rooting for the country we love and live
in right now it's not even close it's
not even close but I will tell you I
mean of course I'm rooting for U.S to to
win it because uh for many different
reasons values all that stuff but if I'm
an analyst not talking about it with who
I want to see wind Iran's the better
team just everybody knows Iran's a
better team us doesn't really have a
their own I think oh one one
Iran record Iran's here's the great
thing about this game anybody can win it
like if you want to have a game that
you're going to watch and see who's
going to win it anybody can win it so
we'll see what's going to happen today
at what time two o'clock two o'clock
Eastern Kevin tell us about the books
tell us about what you're working on
right now uh coming up um please go to
Left Behind 9movie.com Left Behind movie
left behind's based on the books that
were sold 80 million copies of it um
lesbianmovie.com opens on 1100 screens
January 26th the Reagan movie is coming
out sometime next spring I got another
movie called Miracle East Texas that I
did with Lou Gossett Jr and John
ratzenberger that's going to come out
sometime next spring as well
um I'm hosting a trip to Israel
so I hope people join us my wife and I
took people back in 2019 we're leaving
in May of 2023 go to
um Sorbo israeltrip.com Sorbo
israeltrip.com it's gonna be awesome
we got 12 uh 12 days of being uh
basically walking the footsteps of Jesus
it's an amazing amazing trip it's my
fourth time going I was just there in
Spring I did a documentary and I hope
people join us for that as well and what
else going on my book uh true strength
please check out true strength and pluck
out true Faith you can go to
serbostudios.com Sorbo studios.com I
gave you a lot of information here I
hope you guys were running down quickly
there we're plugging on I just put the
link in the chat that says the sore boy
the one going to uh Israel
israel.comstudios.com we got a lot of
great um Christmas items you guys can
get there I've done a lot of wonderful
movies like God's Not Dead what if let
there be light which is right here let
the light is an awesome movie this movie
actually opened you talked about earlier
about and we were talking about in
Hollywood this movie opened number
number uh number two per screen average
against Thor Ragnarok when it came out
four years ago okay number two okay
against a three million dollar movie
Sean Hannity funded it
um three million dollar movie against a
300 million dollar movie Thor Ragnarok I
get a call from Netflix after opening
weekend saying we want to open an
inspirational division with you at
Netflix I had four meetings with him
over the next few months they never did
anything which is really sad and I said
you guys get to pass your ideology and
hate there's 80 million homes in America
that want the kind of movies I do that
are filled with love hope faith and
Redemption and laughter Hollywood won't
do them I do them but we can only get
supported by people like you because we
don't have 100 million dollar
advertising budget so please
serbostudios.com awesome I love that I
love that okay uh Tyler uh uh what do we
have do we have another podcast this
week or no we have another podcast uh
two on Thursday potentially two on
Thursday definitely Andrew Schultz
Andrew Schultz Thursday okay afternoon
p.m okay good and then do we have one on
Friday or no no pretend eventually one
Thursday morning definitely Schultz
Thursday Thursday morning it's very
different than the one on Thursday
afternoon that's not confirmed I got one
more plug
Patriot mobile check that out Patriot
mobile is the fight against Verizon and
Amazon it's a Christian conservative
company based out of Dallas Texas and
they give they give 50 of profits back
to conservative businesses awesome Kevin
you have a lot going on man check it out
all right Kevin appreciate you for
coming out this was fantastic have a
good one guys we'll do this again on
Thursday bye-bye bye-bye